[__] super bowl snack okay
anything a potato skin is a more super
bowl snack than a cocktail weenie dude
it's a cocktail weenie meant for a
cocktail party
packtail is in the name cocktail winning
you're saying it's a low-rent snack
cocktail weenie is just all you're
eating is a hot dog over and over and
over and over pastry if that's like
saying with peanut butter jelly all
you're eating is peanut butter and jelly
no it's the combination of factors that
becomes incredible a cocktail mean also
has no depth
what a potato skin is taking you on a
ride
okay
originally invented as a way to turn a
potato peel into a profitable meal they
took garbage
and figured out a way to make it edible
one of three restaurant chains is
credited as inventing it tgi fridays is
one of the chains you
animal
i don't care you're a pig in a blanket
if i never found out where it came from
i wouldn't change my mind about where
what i feel about it disagree completely